alors qui sont les potentiels candidats
à l'heure actuelle c'est la grande
question c'est aussi la raison pour
laquelle beaucoup pensé jusqu'au bout
killer philippe resterait à matignon
faute de successeur évident naturelles
ou qui s'imposent de soi alors il ya
plusieurs noms qui circulent on parle
beaucoup depuis quelques jours de
florence parly ministre désormais sur
deux le ministre des armées aujourd'hui
cave est ministre du budget sous lionel
jospin
on avait évoqué l'hypothèse de jean yves
le drian le miz affaires étrangères même
si on semble en parler moi mais une fois
encore le seul qu'il le sache c'est
siemens emmanuel macron on parle
également
de monsieur castex qui avait été chargé
de mettre en place le plan de
déconfinement bon voilà jean castex en
quelques mots c'est peut-être dans
salariés ce qu'on a cité le moins connu
du grand public jean castex est avant
tout un vin un fonctionnaire et il était
préfet c'est également un élu il est
maire de prades dans les villes dans les
pyrénées orientales
il a été au cabinet de nicolas sarkozy à
la présidence de la république il est
proche des 2 d'edouard philippe voilà
c'est donc c'est une sorte de héros
serviteur de l'état marqué à droite mais
qui n'est qui n'a pas eu d'engagement et
jaillir très militant très très prononcé
et lorsqu'il s'est agit on avait déjà
évoqué son nom lors du précédent
remaniement où on pensait qu'il pourrait
être nommé ministre l'intérieur ça ne
sais ça ne s'était pas fait à l'époque
et lorsqu'il s'est mis en place le plan
de déconfinement c'est vrai que emmanuel
m'accroche et pour philippe avait confié
à jean castex et que qu'il a fait ce
travail de coordination qui a été jugé
par le président comme étant efficace
donc ça pourrait être une hypothèse on
voit bien qu à profit un profil à la
langue
jean castex voudrait dire que emmanuel
macron attendrait d'un premier ministre
qui soit avant tout j'allais dire
presque une sorte de bon secrétaire
général du gouvernement ces requêtes cac
et qu'il a pour faire tourner la machine
administrative plus que pour donner une
impulsion politique impulsion politique
qui à ce moment-là reviendrait
pleinement à l'elysée donc à emmanuel
macron père